the eastern lands of Europe are vast
flat area called the European Plain
it's intersected with large waterways
thick forests and flush Meadows such
geography meander throughout history
this land had extensive natural
resources that could be used for farming
fishing hunting etc supporting a large
population Howard the flatlands also
paved the way for an ease of access to
many migrating groups and such was the
early history for most of Eastern Europe
with many tribes coming and going but in
the grand scheme of things still leaving
this vast land largely unpopulated
however one people group that would
change this where' the Eastern Slavs
they largely came into the vast lands of
Eastern Europe during the sixth century
Slavic migrations
although valid arguments can be made
that some small Slavic settlements may
have existed in the area for a far
longer time nonetheless the reason why
the Eastern Slavs were the ones able to
populate such a vast area is usually
attributed to two main things first the
sheer number of them and how do we know
this well even though we can't know it
for sure because we have no written
records archeology combined with the
fact that their Western and Sutter
brothers came into central / Western
Europe and such large numbers that even
Western authors were surprised it is
most likely that Eastern Slavs did the
same maybe even on a larger scale second
is the fact that Eastern Slavs as
opposed to the other Slavs used to slash
and burn farming methods mixed with
hunting and gathering this combined with
no crop rotation and very rich soil and
fauna of Eastern Europe meant that they
could produce a lot of food however
would have to resettle every few years
due to hunting and soil depletion how
are these resources could a few years
replenish and be used again by a
different slavic clan resettling all
this meant that you had a large
constantly moving reproducing resettling
population with more than an adequate
food supply which resulted in the fact
that these Slavs were able to settle
this vast area and become in most
regions the majority people group going
down to mostly empty centre going
northward and meeting Baltic and FINA
agree groups and eventually also going
south meeting first the Avars and the
bull karst and the kazars etc in fact it
is largely believed that by the start of
the eighth century most Eastern Slavs
living in the South were forced to pay
some sort of a tribute to the kazars
the important thing to an
Stan about these Eastern Slavs expanding
into the European plain is that they
weren't as homogeneous in culture and
language as we may have thought thanks
to some findings of Slavic birchbark
ridings in Novgorod dating back as far
as the 10th century we can tell with
pretty good certainty that there was
quite a bit of diversity between the
many Eastern Slavic tribes that settled
the European Plain and looking at much
more recent historical Eastern Slavic
documents or even contemporary ones we
can tell by comparison that Eastern
Slavic culture and language was very
much convergent since the 10th century
or even earlier but I digress it was
also around the 8th century and maybe in
some places as early as the 7th century
that this laughs slowly started to move
from the slash-and-burn farming method
and hunting to more reliable crop
rotation farming this meant that the
chaotic autonomous nature of constant
resettling started to be replaced by the
creation of many small self independent
areas for farming communities these
communities were held together by the
main family / clan alliances that
divided up the arable and pastoral land
and together defended it from outsiders
it was into the Slavic society that the
famous Varangians arrived around the 8th
century although again arguments can be
made that Norse people from Sweden may
have come to Eastern Europe even earlier
than that but these would only be
trading expeditions
how are the arrival of the variants at
the 8th century was a much different
story yes some came for trade but many
of them came to plunder and settle the
rich areas around the vast waterways of
Eastern Europe side note here the word
Varangian is mostly used to describe
north / Viking outsiders from Sweden
that usually but not necessarily are in
one way or another connected to the
eastern lands of Europe mostly through
service to some kind of a chieftain
but these arriving varangians also came
two major changes one was the increase
in trade between the Black Sea / the
Middle East and the Baltics and that is
how the Scandinavians acquired the
knowledge of making Damascus steel which
came from India prompting the creation
of the famous Viking
ulfberht sword and second was the
restructuring of the Eastern European
predominately Slavic society this meant
that at the beginning of the 9th century
the close-knit family communities that
existed up until now started to make way
for the creation of large settlements
with ditches ramparts and marketplaces
this in turn filled even more trade and
economic
but also the centralization of power
into small chief dances run from these
newly created fortified towns and since
most of these towns were established by
incoming varangians most of these early
chieftains where varangians ruling over
a much larger Slavic population Howard
they're most likely existed some small
chief dances around that were just
Slavic it was also during this time that
a new word for the Varangians emerge the
ruse derived from the North's words to
row as many of the very Games would do
growing up and down the Eastern European
waterways but it is important to note
the difference between the ruse and the
Varangians unlike the Varangians the
ruse mostly referred to norse people
born and living in eastern europe
including the many chieftains this is
why foreign writers like hamid even
fought LAN who wrote the first-hand
account of a Viking funeral referred to
the Norseman as the ruse because they
came from Eastern Europe not Scandinavia
but the word ruse later started to be
used not just for the Norse people and
the Chieftains but also their subjects
which were mostly Slavic this combined
with the fact that there was chieftains
and people over time assimilated into
the much larger Slavic population the
word ruse
kind of got assimilated as well with all
Eastern Slavs being cold the ruse by
around the 11th and 12th century but
going back to the 9th century from here
as it so often does some chieftain says
started to grow more powerful than
others and absorb the weaker ones
forming large town centres some of which
we would even recognize today and this
is where most historians start referring
to one of the most important Eastern
European historical documents the
Nestor's chronicle or the primary
chronicle or just post now there's many
problems with the primary chronicle that
could have its own entire video like for
example the fact that it most likely
wasn't even written by Nestor or that it
was written two to three hundred years
after their certain events it talks
about or the fact that it starts off
with a mistake stating the wrong
starting date of michael 2/3 rain etc
however this is not to say that we
should dismiss the entire primary
chronicle because not all of it that we
can check with archaeology or other
documents is wrong just some of it is
therefore we have to be aware that the
events it talks about that we at the
moment can check with other means may be
wrong or altered from the truth
so with that and
mind I will cite the primary Chronicle
Hauer also combine it with any other
possible sources to try to get the most
complete picture as it stands the
primary chronicle states that the Slavic
tribes along with some finno-ugric
tribes rebelled against their Varangian
overlords and chased them out of the
lands of Eastern Europe in the early 9th
century now this may be true for some
chieftain says that existed at the time
but Eastern Europe wasn't one big
unified area and what may have occurred
and one of the chieftains is probably
didn't happen in all of them after that
it is said that the people who threw out
the Varangian started to squabble
amongst themselves and chaos and suits
to fix this problem some of these trap's
invited back to Varangians to restore
order the varangians agreed and came in
862 862 with a large force led by person
named Tariq
however it is debated if runic really
came being invited or just came as
another conquer trying to get land for
himself just like many Vikings did in
Western Europe it is also very likely
that the Rohtak came to take land from
another very angry and slashers and the
expulsion story never happened
being invented years later to make it
seem like a union between the variants
and the Slav static conquest there's
also a Byzantine source stating a
receipt of Constantinople in 860 where
the ruse laid siege to the city before
retreating this is the same year as the
early estimate of Roddick's arrival to
Eastern Europe so we know it was an
early it may have been a different route
chieftain of Eastern Europe or it may
have been an independent raiding
expedition of some rows people wanting
to get rich or it may have been an
expedition by the chief of the north and
lands that the relic was now conquering
the latter would make some sense as
rorek would naturally want to attack
during the absence of the chieftain and
his army on top of that the Byzantine
sources state that the ruse suddenly
lifted the siege leaving even though
they had the upper hand so it may have
well been the chieftain quickly trying
to get back to his lands because
cirrhotic was there whatever may have
happened we know that the roerich want
solidifying his reign over the northern
lands and supposedly founding Novgorod
in the later half of the ninth century
but this has been disproven as
archaeological finds state the
settlement of velikiy Novgorod to late
10th century however this probably was
just a misinterpretation as Novgorod
just means new city or new fortification
so
new city was a d new city shortly after
that Rohtak died in 879 leaving his
kingdom and a very young son egor to
quote unquote his skin oleg the primary
chronicle states that alec went on an
expansionist campaign conquering many
chief dances and cities including Kiev
in 882 which he promptly named as the
capital of a kingdom from then on known
as the Kiev Andrews he then died in 912
after which Igor Eriksson succeeded him
but there's a kazar letter from 940
mentioning all like being the king of
the ruse well after the primary
chronicle states that he died so this
prompted some historians to think that
maybe all I didn't really die in 912 but
actually had a power struggle with Igor
1 to the 9th century whichever it may
have been Igor did succeed all like
eventually becoming the king of the Kiev
and rose in 940s he went on to fight the
Byzantines probably oversaw some raiding
expeditions along the Caspian Sea and
eventually was killed by his own
subjects for demanding too many tributes
/ taxes in 945 but his wife Olga took
the initiative and as a region for their
young son so Atlas loved hunted down the
people that killed her husband
established new frontier castles
centralized the power within the kingdom
and enacted first-ever law reforms in
Eastern Europe she was also the first
high-ranking person in Eastern Europe to
convert to Christianity in
Constantinople and therefore today she's
known as saint olga of kiev and even
though his mother was a christian
svetislav was a starch Bagan his entire
life with that sense we had to Slav
fought many successful wars against the
Byzantines the bull guards the kazars
who were replaced by another invading
nomadic group the Pechenegs etc forming
at the time the largest empire in Europe
Howard 970 his streak would end being
defeated by the Byzantines who then
bribed the pigeon eggs to ambush him on
his way home from the unsuccessful
campaign the ambush was successful
killing svetislav in 972 and since he
didn't have time to solidify most of his
conquests lots of the land he conquered
was lost in the subsequent six year long
secession crisis between his three sons
the eldest yaropolk prince of kiev the
second eldest oleg prince of drily Nia
and the youngest and also a bastard Vlad
mere prince of novgorod yaropolk in kiev
was poised to become the king of the
ruse and as such raided to find it
causes belly for attacking one of his
brothers
and when one dubious claim came in 977
he seized on the opportunity and
attacked oleg quickly conquering to
Alenia and killing his brother he then
turned his attention to Vladimir but
after Vladimir found out about his
brother's death he knew that the balance
of power within the kingdom wasn't in
his favor and fled leaving yellow book
as the sole ruler of Kiev in ruse but
what do you mean had a plan in mind he
fled to Scandinavia to one of his
relatives Haakon Sigurdsson and vassal
king of norway under the famous Harald
Bluetooth he asked hackin for help who
did but Vladimir most likely heavily
recruited soldiers on his own promising
land money and seats at his court once
they retake Kiev in ruse with this new
Iranian army assembled Vladimir returned
to Eastern Europe power on his way to
give he stopped by bullets and asked the
local princess to marry him she refused
to marry a bastard and so Vladimir did
the only sensible thing he could have
done conquered the entire town killed
her father and forced her to marry him
anyways after that he also conquered
Smolensk after which he could finally
move on to beseech Kiev where in 978
through deceit he managed to kill his
brother yaropolk ending the six-year
long succession crisis
Vladimir went on to solidify his kingdom
and reconquer most of the lands lost
since his father's death but at this
point Kiev and ruse was a cultural and
religious melting pot most of the
peasants practiced Slavic paganism but
they were also Khazar Jews Norse pagans
volga bogar muslims finna auric pagans
christians and even the nobility
practiced a weird mixture of north
slavic paganism all of these different
religious beliefs naturally didn't
provide much stability to the kingdom so
bloody really decided it's time to
reform the religion of the rose people
and send out an voice to go find out
more about all the various religions he
was put off by Islam's taboo on drinking
stating that drinking is the joy of all
ruse we cannot exist without that
pleasure you rejected Judaism as well as
he didn't like the fact that they lost
control of their holy land and in the
end he settled on Orthodox Christianity
being told their churches where much
more lavish and grandiose than the ones
of the Catholics in the West Ladd Amir
was baptized in 988 and said about
converting the rest of his subjects
effectively closing the pages of the
formerly pagan Kiev and ruse that is
where I will end my early Eastern Slavic
history video please consider
subscribing and/or supporting me on
patreon I'm also planning to do more
early history of certain people groups
at some point in the future so if you're
into that stick around for history